welcome back to New rockstars I'm
Jessica Clemens and this is a breakdown
of what if season 2 episode 4 what if
Iron Man crashed into the Grand Master
Eric says he's out on paternity leave
but I'm pretty sure he's sucking down
dog park flavored cocktails and got his
holiday break started early but today
we're going scene by scene for all the
Fast and Furious Mad Max pod racing
animation details you might have missed
and before we get started if you're
looking to spend a little bit of that
Holiday Cash head on over to nerd rot.
shop you can grab a shirt we made that's
directly inspired by this episode I have
a sweatshirt of it right here you see
how cool it is look how amazing it is is
it beautiful we o have hats hoodies and
enough Loki merch to last us until
season 3 please give us a season 3 I
would love that Kevin figy if you're
listening I'm begging you I will I I'll
kill for you anyways let's get into it
we start on The Abridged Marvel Studios
logo with the animation brush Strokes
that we've seen for the last few
episodes during a screening of these
episodes for the media Marvel also
showed off trailers for some of their
2024 animated shows that included
another new Marvel Studios logo this
time dropping the studio so it just
reads marel animation and I'll be
curious if they stick with this bumper
or switch their newer one for the future
animated series we we get our first
previously on for the series to help
explain why gamor was present for the
events of the last season finale the
episode was originally set to air during
season 1 but was moved to this season
due to co delays director of this
episode Brian Andrew said this episode
was unchanged from the version that
would have aired during season 1 but he
lied this previously on Section was
added for the new season and while most
of the shots in this opening are taken
from the original season one finale this
shot of young Gamora is the new one for
this episode this episode was also
rumored to be called what if gamorra
killed Thanos when it was planned for
season 1 and I think this title changes
at we open on the ending of The Avengers
Tony directs the atomic bomb into the
chitauri command center but this time
doesn't fall back through the sanctuary
Wormhole instead going on a 2001 Space
Odyssey Planet hopping tour reminiscent
of Thor's trippy Journey Through the
cosmos and Ragnarok Tony is voed by Mick
Winger reprising his role from season 1
and yesterday's Christmas episode he
crashes into the grand Master's Palace
on sakar and meets The Grandmaster
himself voiced by Jeff Goldblum and
topaz played by the frequent Tao watiti
collaborator Rachel house returning from
Thor Ragnarok Tony suit Sparks and topaz
hit him with the foam and I love this
little detail we see later that the
grandmas is a huge fan of Chariots
exploding during the Grand Prix so I
imagine they had these foam cannons
installed in case one of the burning
cars makes it all the way up to the
tower Grandmaster tells Tony he's on S
car and Tony says this I'm sorry Planet
as in I'm lost in space uh yes and yes
this would be in fact Tony's first time
on a new planet Lost in Space is also a
reference to the 1965 show and the 2018
Netflix reboot of the same name about a
family finding themselves stranded on an
alien planet The Grandmaster recognizes
Tony due to his her and the Battle of
New York and the Battle of Earth he's an
elder of the universes and can travel
through space and time which is likely
how he knows Tony has defeated Thanos in
some realities though Tony was notably
absent in 838 fight against Thanos we do
know he was around that Universe for a
time though it is possible that the
Grandmasters simply refer into the
Battle of New York as Thanos was a
mastermind behind that attack The
Grandmaster calls Tony by a few
nicknames including Rocket Man and Tin
Man before landing on metal Mojo man
Mojo is a frequent foil to the X-Men in
the comics but uh I wouldn't certainly
call his physique you know metal this
could also be a tangential reference to
the Jimmy Hendrick song Mojo man which
has the lyrics I see electric flames you
all they are burning all over Mojo man
from a far away land it's also possible
that Jeff goldoon just likes literation
in groovy words like Mojo he be like
that Tony says this okay wizard of odds
I need to get back to to Earth Pronto
damn after ragn Rod's Pure Imagination
sequence I was really hoping for a Wonka
tie in Tony's O's reference will come
full circle soon enough though oh
I'm the Grand Master says this but first
got to stay and celebrate with us it's
my uh 21st 21st what birthday I know I
know okay his 21st on the surface this
seems like just a joke about Jeff gold
boom's age but being an elder of the
universe I'm wondering if he's actually
celebrating like the 21st century
Millennium he's old he also loves
birthdays in Thor Ragnarok as Bruce
Banner was piloting The Grandmaster
stolen ship he presses a button that
activates a birthday celebration
sequence complete with banging
soundtrack disco lights and fireworks
topz used the APPL name melt stick to
melt a statue of someone playing a horn
in the time and setting I believe this
is a statue of heale playing the Yer
horn a horn used to Signal the beginning
of Ragnarok it also could be just a
statue of some guards with horns we see
later in the episode The grandm says
this so let's make some noise right
right dollies and Clyde dollies and CES
I'm pretty confident that's just a
reference to the Chariots doll's being
platforms with wheels and Clyde's being
shorthand for Clydesdale horses during
our research we also found an episode of
Bewitched where Samantha turns a woman
named Dolly into a race horse and I
needed to share it valkyrie's vehicle
has these three fins which are nod to
the wings of Thor's helmet you can see
Rosco a gladiator who participated on
the sakaran rebellion and Thor Ragnarok
and eventually made it to be a Statesman
as well as tasun and corg and in the
earlier scene we saw Biff hanging in the
grandmaster's palace since this a placed
well before Hulk arrived in AAR then
maybe these Gladiators were here for a
while but again time works differently
on sakar as we know Tony refers to this
race is similar to Formula 1 something I
assume he's all too familiar with from
this time in Monaco facing off against
Whiplash while Eric is out on paternity
leave he has mandated that every video
has at least one lost reference go back
to my videos and see if you can find
them so here goes nothing she Dodges out
of the way of another car that gets
sucked up into the jet like an engine of
another vehicle just like the guy in
Lost pilot the Grand Master says this to
Tony oh look at that flame he was made
to be Road pill ironic considering
Tony's parents ended up as
roadkill I'm not sorry I'm not sorry I
bring up his dead parents a lot in the
series already space has a reputation
for being lonely but when you're playing
Warframe it's not lonely at all more
than 75 million people are playing
Warframe a Cooperative free-to-play
third person online action game that
makes you the main character in a
constantly evolving Space Opera that's
crazy fun in Warframe you take on the
role of a tenno an ancient warrior race
who Pilots the tier warframes EXO suits
loaded with a bazillion weapons that let
you slice shoot and explode your way
through the cosmos any way you like one
of the things that has kept Warframe
going for so long are regular content
updates its new cinematic Quest Whispers
in the walls is available now and is
introducing new areas to explore a new
warframes to explore them with and new
weapons so you can customize your build
Whispers in the walls plot explores the
Deep Secrets surrounding the mysterious
outbreak in Troy and the entity only
known as the man in the wall plus you'll
meet the murmur a brand new big bad get
to use the grimoire new void powered
weapon and pilot the corvex the newest
Warframe who's loaded with deadly
radiation weapons if you haven't played
Warframe before you can register for
free today using the link in the
description join more than 75 million
players on PC Xbox series X PS5 Nintendo
switch and More in are playing one of
the most critically acclaimed
Cooperative online action games with
more than 10 years of content today the
crowd throws chinchillas at a crash
Valkyrie and the grandm says this we
used to throw rotten food but given the
recent famines leaving people uh how do
I put this peckish it's considered UNC
yes unfortunately the grandmas sugar
coating the plight of the sakarians
isn't new in Thor Ragnarok he bristled
at topaz referring to some workers as
slaves and instead opted for prisoners
with jobs Valkyrie grabs a drink from
the Sakari and Dom tetto and it's the
same brand she swigs and Ragnarok score
topaz calls for the champion to be
released and everyone expecting Hulk
doesn't have their MCU timeline down
like we do out bth Snuffy the elephant
monster Snuffy could be a reference to
the Muppet of the same name though I
would advise you not to Google that on
your word computer because you're going
to get some weird images Tony attempts
to suit up but as he puts on the glove
he says uh why is it sticky ooh assuming
The Grandmaster had his hands on this
last I think we all know why though
interestingly this Tech Tool the pizza's
body was developed for the mark 42 armor
and Iron Man 3 after the battle of New
York I guess in this what if Universe
Tony developed this Tech earlier gamor
emerges from the smoke to hunt Tony down
for his actions against Thanos but
before she can land the killing blow
they both get zaed with the same taser
detainment disc that Thor does in Thor
Ragnarok Tony is able to remove his
restraining trip via his Arc Reactor
still embedded in his chest as he didn't
remove it until the end of Iron Man 3
Tony says this he not hanging around to
play Dr moro's Hunger Games that's for
sure a reference to both the HG Wells
novel The Island of Dr Moro but a mad
scientist who creates human animal
hybrids in The Hunger Games a novel
about kids killing each other to win a
tournament in the center of my Tik Tok
for you page I love Josh Hutcherson just
not that much attempting to escape cor
Leroy Jenkins his way in and hits the
guards with old hulky Hulk we've already
seen a call back to this and what if
this season the animators just can't
resist it cor goo says this oh Tony Tony
Tony you blink Tony Tony Tony is the
name of an R&B group from the '90s corg
is really leaning into the Twan band
baby gamorra catches up and grabs the
same gun Loki and managed to get their
hands on as they escape sakar and
Ragnarok Tony lays into Gamora saying
this do you know what it's like to see
your home world destroyed almost brought
to its knees by a Madman oh jeez Tony I
don't know does she Tony ask corg is
this Grandmaster guy as bad as my gut
says he is oh this one time he used me
as a paper weight and uh can you imagine
how that felt just to have to sit on
paper which is my Nemesis that's the
second core rock paper scissors joke
this season and the third in the MCU
I'll give it a pass since this episode
was originally intended for season 1 but
I'm on to you writers as cor says Tony's
mother must be proud of him being Iron
Man Iron being what I assume is a very
impressive type of rock to you know rock
like people at the bar Court says this
look at this little thing I think I'll
name him niik after my friend Jeffrey we
did some pretty deep digging here and
while Jeffrey is likely a reference to
Jeff Goldblum we're pretty sure that
Nikos is a reference to a relatively
obscure Marvel character named a mil
Nikos and the comics is best friends
with Dr Michael morbius and look here M
cor mobus gamorra steals the Melt stick
from topaz and melts some guards noting
that it smells like burnt Yaro root and
Ragnarok topaz says it smells like burnt
toast but Yara root has been mentioned
in the MCU a few times first and
Guardians of the Galaxy Volume 2 and
later we see in an episode of I am group
working as a team Tony corg and Valkyrie
get to work creating a new Iron Man suit
and Tony challenges the grandm to a race
for the planet The Grandmaster rolls up
in the car sporting the Iron Man
signature red and gold which is corny as
hell his racer appear similarity to ship
the Commodore so maybe he's been an Iron
Man Fan for some some time and then Tony
says this slap me and call me Sparta cuz
that's a chariot of course a reference
to the 1994 action comedy cult classic
blank Man starring Damon Wayne slap me
around and call me Susan Tony slaps a
comm's device on the roof of gamora's
car and hits her with a let's keep in
touch hags like he's signing a seventh
grade yearbook or me signing my like
nephew's yearbook today during the race
core karate chops one of the cars and it
makes the Star Wars Blaster sound car
spills out of the mouth of a Gundam
looking thing as the course turns into
something definitely reminiscent of a
Hot Wheels track we've seen Tony's suit
turn into a lot of things but now it's a
godamn Transformer as it turned into a
Formula 1 style race car The Grandmaster
activates some coarse obstacles and sets
loose two more elephant monsters that
run to block the entrance to the arena
reminding me of King Kong at the end of
the race the first key and Ready Player
One Tony says this thank you Gamora is
that Dutch Swedish maybe Gamora is of
course not from Earth but the closest
Earthly counterpart to that name would
be the biblical city gamor that was
destroyed by God fitting as gamora's own
planet was destroyed by a Godlike figure
than so you know it goes hand in hand
toony twists his Arc Reactor powering up
his car and nudges Out The Grandmaster
to reach the Finish Line first his car
bust through the Finish Line reminded me
a bit of light cycle from Tron Valkyrie
crashes into topaz an attempt to save
Tony causing the Melt stick to melt The
Grandmaster but since he is a moral he
simply turns into a puddle the sakaran
crown Valkyrie their King this is now
the second time she's unwillingly become
king in the MCU Tony says this well I
would but it's time to go home Pepper's
waiting for me more of a salt man myself
of course not only a joke about salt and
pepper but cor's Affinity to rocks and
The Rock jokes Gamora takes Tony into
face Thanos but it's a double cross as
she uses the Melt stick before we cut to
Black and I guess we'll never know what
happens P the season one finale picks up
right after this moment and to jog your
memory Tony and Gamora take thanos's
Gauntlet to ner and melt it down into
lava before Gamora is recruited by The
Watcher The Watcher refers to Gamora as
the destroyer of Thanos so it sounds
like the Melt stick does work on
eternals or at least eternals with no
Affinity stones and a deviant Gene this
episode had the first previously on and
it also has the first post credit scene
the Grandmaster asked topaz for a bucket
in a mop and judging by Tony's sticky
glove I don't want to know where that
bucket was before now and that's it for
my breakdown of season 2 episode 4 of
what if this is a huge huge huge thanks
to John CA Brandon baric and Noah Chen
for helping me write this video I I I'll
be their vessels I owe them everything
we've got a lot more what if breakdowns
coming your way and it truly takes a
village for us to do this follow me on
Twitter at Lulu Clemens follow new
rockstars and be sure to subscribe for
more breakdowns of everything you love
thanks for watching I'll see you guys
later
[Music]
[Applause]
la